رايه جديده رفعت في ساحه وزاره الخارجيه
الفنلنديه في هيلسنكي هي ليست مجرد عضو
جديد في النيتو بل هي جبهته الاطول الان
على تخوم روسيا فبانضمامها اتسعت حدود
الحلف الغربي مع روسيا
ربما يكون هناك بعض التوتر على الحدود
لاظهار ان روسيا ما تزال مهمه فنلندا كانت
هدفا لامبرياليه الروسيه لقرون وعلى روسيا
ان تنظر الى نفسها في المراه لترى من
المسؤول عما يحدث الان في اركان مختلفه من
اوروبا
في الشارع يعتقد بعضهم ان الفنلندا الان
حلفاء يحمونها لكن العلاقه ثنائيه الاتجاه
والفائده متبادله في نظر الفنلنديين هي
الدوله السابعه للحلف على بحر البلطيق
فنلندا ستزود النيتو بنحو مليون جندي
احتياط مدربين وجيش قوي جدا وسلاح جو مزود
حديثا بطائرات اف 35 فنلندا هي الدوله
الوحيده التي لم تتراجع جاهزيتها الحربيه
بعد نهايه الحرب البارده وما زالت لدينا
خدمه التجنيد الاجباري اعتقد ان الناتو
حصل على عضو جيد جدا
يدل على فنلندا تحديد طبيعه عضويتها في
الحلف وما اذا كانت ستسمح بنشر قوات دائمه
للنيتو واسلحته النوويه على اراضيها
انتهى زمن الحياد العسكري لفنلندا يقول
مسؤولوها ان تغير البيئه الامنيه في
محيطهم بسبب السلوك الروسي غير عقيده عدم
الانحياز التي ظلت ثابته لعقود لكنهم
يؤكدون ان الغايه هي الردع والحمايه وليس
الاستفزاز والعدوان محمد المدهون الجزيره
هيلسنكي